wir haben hunderte instagram follower
und whatsapp kontakte und fühlen uns
trotzdem einsam haben das internet und
social media einen paradoxen effekt auf
uns in einer eu befragung von 2020
fühlten sich 35 prozent der 18 bis 25
jährigen in mehr als der hälfte der zeit
einsam aber darüber spricht kaum jemand
einsamkeit ist ein schaf behaftet das
thema und vor allem öffentlich wollte
niemand mit mir darüber sprechen aber
mir viele leute geschrieben und mir
gesagt wie es ihnen mit dem thema
einsamkeit geht und ich darf sie
zitieren ich war einfach traurig weil
ich allein war ich hatte das gefühl
nicht allein klarzukommen
jedes mal wenn ich zurück in meine
stelle wohnung die versuche ich mich von
der einsamkeit abzulenken manchmal denke
ich ich dürfte mich nicht einsam fühlen
weil es so wirkt es ging aus allen bei
instagram so gut da fehlt mir manchmal
der bezug zur realität
das internet macht es hier also einsam
in der älteren generation war mir das
thema einsamkeit bewusst in der eu
befragung sagen 23 prozent der über
65-jährigen dass sie in mehr als der
hälfte der zeit einsam sitzt man sieht
auch wie die
bekannten in unserem alltag zu hause
sitzen und
und große schwierigkeiten haben durch
krone war mann der eigentlich wert wir
sind ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr groß
rausgekommen und in dieser generation
kann das internet einen anderen effekt
haben spielerisch ein oligarch nach
jahre aber man kann dadurch aber am
leben meine frau ist in 86 und wir beide
sind schon da und hier kann das internet
weniger einsam machen und darum geht es
in diesem video einsamkeit und das
internet und wie unterschiedlich ist
auch die junge und die alte generation
wirken kann und wir schauen uns an wie
man mit dem gefühl der einsamkeit
umgehen kann
[Musik]
lasst uns ganz vorne anfangen was ist
einsamkeit eigentlich einsamkeit ist
nicht gleich allein sein alleinsein
bedeutet da ist niemand anderes anwesend
und das kann ja auch ein angenehmes
gefühl sein aber einsamkeit ist nie
angenehm das ist ein schmerzhaftes
gefühl wenn man nicht die gewünschten
sozialen beziehungen hat und das kann
passieren wenn man alleine ist aber man
kann es auch empfinden wenn man in einer
gruppe ist es ist das subjektive gefühl
keine nähe zu spüren als ich angefangen
habe für das thema zu recherchieren habe
ich zuerst gedacht dass ich gar nicht so
oft einsam bin aber dann habe ich
gemerkt dass ich oft angst davor habe
einsam zu sein also ich habe angst davor
ausgegrenzt zu werden oder auch nicht
dazuzugehören
den punkt den sie gerade gemacht haben
den höre ich in erfahrungsberichten
schon häufiger auch gerade von jüngeren
menschen die es gewohnt sind eigentlich
immer unter anderen zu sein oder immer
mit anderen im austausch zu sein jetzt
auch beispielsweise über soziale medien
so dass quasi
dieses gefühl gar nicht erst hochkommen
kann oder man versucht das ebenso weit
von sich fernzuhalten wie es nur
irgendwie geht wie ist das denn bei euch
wann habt ihr euch zuletzt einsam
gefühlt schreibt es uns gerne in die
kommentare
zur erinnerung jeder dritte der 18 bis
25 jährigen fühlt sich immer wieder
einsam wie kann das denn sein wenn das
die generation ist die total vernetzt
digital und mobil ist jahre hoffmann hat
in ihrem podcast zum thema einsamkeit
mit vielen menschen über das thema
gesprochen ich habe jahre gefragt was
ihre erkenntnis ist warum fühlen sich
junge menschen einsam ist kriegt so
paradox und man denkt immer junge leute
können gar nicht einsam sein ja weil
egal wo auf der welt ich bin ich habe
immer irgendwie verbindung die schaffen
kann aber was man nicht unterschätzen
darf sind natürlich ganz viele andere
parameter zum einen dass der vergleich
durch social media extrem groß geworden
ist also wenn du einem vergleich jetzt
stets und ständig und du denkst du bist
nicht gut genug dann macht es ganz
großen selbst werden und wenn dann sechs
wert angeknackst ist so du denkst du
hast nicht aus dann gehörst du da ja gar
nicht dazu
und wenn du dich dazu gehörst zu einer
community wenn er nicht dazu gehört zum
kreis der schöne und tollen und das auch
immer ja dann bist du natürlich der
außenseite und die außenseiterinnen dann
bist du einsam aber es ist nicht total
der widerspruch dass sich diese so
vernetzte generation einsam fühlt sehe
ich da gar nicht so einen direkten
widerspruch darin dass man sehr vernetzt
und auch sehr mobil ist und sich
gleichzeitig einsam fühlen kann weil
dieses zumindest oberflächlich vernetzt
sein und mobil sein eben auch bedeutet
dass man ständig zwischen verschiedenen
welten hin und her pendelt und dann eben
häufig die zeit fehlt konstante
beziehungen zu führen wo man auf
menschen trifft die einen schon sehr
sehr lange kennen und auch die
lebensgeschichte verstehen und einordnen
können also trotz der vielen möglichen
kontakte im internet fehlen die tiefen
gespräche in der realität es scheint
also nicht die quantität eine rolle zu
spielen sondern die qualität der
sozialen kontakte aber auch da ist jeder
mensch unterschiedlich weil ihr
einsamkeit ein subjektives empfinden ist
es kann zum beispiel ältere menschen
geben die alleine wohnen und die kaum
noch soziale kontakte haben und da geht
es darum dass sie überhaupt noch mit
jemandem in kontakt treten und nicht um
die qualität des contents und auch wenn
einsamkeit ein subjektives gefühl ist
kann es ein gesellschaftliches problem
sein in großbritannien ist einsamkeit
sogar ein politisches thema das man
richtig bekämpfen möchte
2018 gibt es hier ein einsamkeit
ministerium das einzige weltweit
beispielsweise postboten und wenn wir
rausgehen und es ist markiert da wohnt
jemand alleine dann kam die extra mehr
zeit eingeplant um dort noch ein
pläuschchen das ist was total schön was
simpel ist was mit totale wertschätzung
ist weil man die leute wieder abholen
ein weiterer punkt in der 1 als
strategie in großbritannien die
digitalisierung von senioren und
seniorinnen damit sie mehr teilhaben
können und weniger einsam sind in
deutschland gibt es kein ministerium das
sich darum kümmert aber es gibt jemanden
der das im kleinen macht dagmar hirche
die seit 2003 zehn menschen über 65
jahren rund um das internet also ich
halte davon gar keine ahnung womit auch
nicht an und weiß nicht irgendwann habe
ich dann jetzt muss ich
ja weil das schwein so wenn sie irgendwo
was gefragt haben können sie mir mal
bitte sagen um die es da geht man ins
internet
ja und wenn ich kein internet an was
mache ich denn dann und dann habe ich
nicht angemeldet und bin natürlich genau
so ängstlich und unwissen dahin ich hab
mich
das hat dagmar hirche geändert den
vergangenen acht jahren hat sie
insgesamt 14.000 senioren und
seniorinnen geschult meistens zwischen
70 und 90 jahren da liegt der größte
bedarf deutschlandweit nutzen die über
70-jährigen zu 52 prozent das internet
und davon nur 36 prozent das mobile
internet ich wollte von frauchen wissen
was nehmen sie denn in den schulungen
durch das ist immens gibt ob da kommt
jemand unser gibt es eine pflanzen
ergibt vogel es gibt es sonst irgend
eine app oder wir schulen wie
funktioniert google map oder wie
funktionieren die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel oder verkehrsmittel an
sich und nach vier jahren nutzen das
auch die meisten teilnehmer und
teilnehmerinnen ich suche wenn ich
irgendwo hin muss oder dann frag mal bei
google nach wo ist das und wo ist dies
oder wie komme ich dahin bvg apps und
dergleichen das ist ja alles ganz
wichtig und ich hab natürlich diese
toiletten
es gehört zur welt es gehört einfach zum
leben es ist ja egal wann man sollte
keinen keinen termin bei irgendwelchen
ärzten bekommen die sind alle so weil es
mich dass sie kaum ans telefon gehen
können und so schreibt man ruft uns mal
angebrochen einen neuen termin oder oder
sagen gleich den termin den man gerne
hätte es gehört zum leben führt lisa und
annemarie gehört das internet
mittlerweile ganz normal zum alltag dazu
und oftmals lässt es sehe vor allem
teilhaben und das hier ist ein handstand
unser enkelsohn uns aus wie magisch ist
also da ist man überall verbunden davon
stand man weiß dass man im pott gelernt
haben und auch keine angst nach oben
drauf zu drücken wenn es mein essen
drückt man nimmt mal falsch aber aber es
geht immer wieder
das kann man gar nicht beschreiben wie
schön das ist ich telefoniere auch immer
per video mit meinem opa der kanzler
nicht viel im internet aber dass das
kann er sie macht ihr es kommuniziert
ihr auch über das internet mit an
großeltern oder gehört ihr zu älteren
generation und seit online erzählt es
uns gerne und schreibe es in die
kommentare
wir brauchen nicht aus der einsamkeit zu
kommen
wichtig ist natürlich immer wie man das
internet nutzt man kann jetzt nicht
sagen für die alten menschen ist das
internet gut und für die jungen leute
ist es schlecht so einfach ist es
natürlich nicht es kommt immer darauf an
wie man es nutzt und wie es einem damit
geht und eine sache will ich noch betont
wenn man sich eine längere zeit einsam
fühlt und da nicht alleine raus kommt
dann sollte man sich eventuell hilfe
suchen aber ein stück weit gehört
einsamkeit auch zeitweise zum leben dazu
und ist ganz normal und gar nicht
schlimm auch wenn es negativ konnotiert
ist einsamkeit ist per definition
irgendwie etwas negatives dann würde ich
ihnen auf jeden fall recht geben aber
das alleine sein ist nicht zwangsläufig
etwas negatives und das kann durchaus
auch ein ansatzpunkt sein zu sagen wir
menschen sollten versuchen das alleine
seien auch wieder zu genießen oder
allein ein positiver aspekte kennen zu
lernen und man genau hinzuhören was
kommen uns denn eigentlich für gedanken
wenn wir alleine sind gerade wenn man
das im alltag eigentlich immer
unterdrückt also wenn man immer versucht
irgendwie beschäftigt zu sein und wenn
man an der bahnhaltestelle steht dann
greift man nach dem handy und macht
irgendwas am smartphone um bloß nicht
irgendwie da so verloren und alleine rum
zu stehen und da würde ich schon sagen
warum nicht einfach mal ausprobieren was
das mit uns macht wenn wir dieses
alleine sein ganz aktiv aufsuchen um das
eben auch die sich einfach mal
auszuprobieren und diese erfahrung
möglicherweise zu machen dass das auch
positive seiten haben kann für mich
würde das also heißen meine angst vor
der einsamkeit überwinden und mich damit
auseinandersetzen also vielleicht mal
alleine spazierengehen oder alleine in
ein café gehen fühlt sich vielleicht ein
bisschen seltsam an aber ich probier's
mal aus wie geht's euch damit macht ihr
das vielleicht schon oder wollt ihr
jetzt auch häufiger bewusst alleine sein
schreibt mir in die kommentare
[Musik]
falls ihr euch einsam fühlt und da
alleine nicht rauskommt in der infobox
haben wir ein paar nummern und adressen
für euch helfen könnten